let's figure out 7 12 minus 6 13. and in
order to be able to do this we need to
find a common denominator we notice that
they're not common right over here here
the denominator is 12 here it is 13. and
the common denominator is going to be
the least common multiple of 12 and 13
and 12 and 13 don't share no common
factors other than one so their least
common multiple is actually just going
to be 12 times 13. actually i'm just
going to leave it written as 12 times 13
so let's first let's first try to
rewrite this right over here and i'll do
the denominator first so 7 over 12
instead of the denominator being 12 i'm
going to write it as 12
times 13.
well if we multiply the denominator by
13 in order to not change the value of
the fraction we need to multiply the
numerator times 13.
so i'm notice all i did is i multiplied
the numerator and the denominator by the
same number that's equivalent to just
multiplying it by 13 over 13 or one so
this is still equivalent to 7 12.
similarly
let me do this one in blue right over
here the common denominator we want is
12 times 13.
so here in the denominator we multiply
so i'll write let me write it as 13
times 12
13 times 12. well if we multiply the
denominator by 12 we have to multiply
the numerator by 12 as well so i'll
write the numerator as 6 times 12.
notice here we multiplied the numerator
and the denominator by 13. here we
multiplied the numerator and the
denominator by 12. how did i know to
multiply this by 12 well the common
denominator is 13 times 12. so here i
multiplied the denominator by 12 so i
have to do the numerator by 12. the
common denominator here is 13 times 12.
but here i had to multiply by 13 to get
it so i had to multiply the numerator by
13 as well
but now we are ready to subtract you
might say hey sal hold on what are these
actually evaluate to well maybe that's a
good idea let's figure that out first so
this is equal to
7 times 13 let's see 7 times 13 is 70
plus 21. it's 91
over 12 times 13. let's say i haven't
memorized my 13 times tables so we know
that 12 times 12 is 144. you put on one
more 12 you get to 156
1
56 so 91 over 156 is the exact same
thing as 7 12. i just multiplied the
numerator and the denominator by 13. and
from that we are going to subtract
6 times 12 6 times 12 is 72
72 over well we already figured out what
12 times 13 is or what 13 times 12 is it
is
1
56 and now that we have a common
denominator we can rewrite this as being
equal to
91 minus 72
91
minus 72
minus 72
minus 72 over 156 and i'll just write
that in a neutral color over
156. see if it was 92 minus 72 would be
20 that's one less so it's going to be
19 over 156
so this is going to be equal to 19
over
156 and as far as i can tell
not let's see 19 does not go into 156
let me just make sure of that somehow
magically 156 isn't a multiple of 19 so
i could simplify this
so see 19 is almost 20
so maybe let's see if it'll go seven
times seven times nine is 63 7 times one
is seven plus six is thirteen let's see
the difference here actually i could
have gone in one more time
let's see so let's do it eight times
eight times nine is seventy-two
eight times one is eight plus seven is
fifteen yeah you have a remainder here
so this doesn't go evenly this isn't
this isn't divisible by 19 and they
don't share any other common factor so
we've simplified it about as much as we
can this is equal to
19 over 156